yes hi oh I have control over hitting
the camera no I don't hi guys hey I'm
Greg Alba and I'm Cara
Harrison services from the YouTube
channel tarath Erickson you can go check
out our video that we did on her channel
we shot it here but it's not a reaction
it's like a commercial thing go find out
what that's all about kind of my child
get commercial skips commercial jumps
hey Tara Erickson there's a final
trailer out a final trailer for a movie
that you have not seen any trailers for
no but you did do a little research on
it when a little bit helps out a little
bit valerian and the city of a thousand
planets let's do this react I'm really
looking forward to it all right all
right let's do it meet you I haven't
seen any of them there's a lot of idea
what this looks I'm going in cold
despite a commercial for the commercial
at the beginning
[Music]
[Music]
that is true all right the city of
thousands after century prosperity an
unknown full confidence oil we have
created
[Music]
Asian Sumerian and Lori you were less
than ten hours to find the place
eliminated Oh Tara not
well that's Wow we're crazy shot
[Music]
no time for this
ah
[Music]
Wow cool right so Coleman guys like Star
Trek and Star Wars like combine avatar
oh my gosh it's like an avatar thing
that was the first thinking round with
that first pick up with the avatar this
guy whatever that was but oh my gosh the
monster in the plane that they're
shooting at looks amazing he reminds me
of job the Hutt like white and to move
the designs of everything yeah how sweet
man so cool and this is one of those
things where it's very effects-heavy but
the effects have to look spectacular
Danny and then we can do and I think the
reason why it's especially impressive in
effects territory because this doesn't
look like who's the studio that's doing
this as STX entertainment who are very
nice people who have put me a little
goodies in the back you're all
flattering yeah yeah this isn't like
Warner Brothers or Universal Studio
right my name's budget and it's not like
you got James Cameron or George Lucas
backing right as Luke based on whose
last crazy visual spectacle was the
Fifth Element so to see this level of
oppressive effects for a graphic novel
that a lot of people in the states are
not familiar with right I mean it does
look amazing that shot when I kept
starting from the director of this this
like get cutting to like the movie yeah
but it looked like one long shot of Dane
DeHaan does running through these things
and knocking things down with his head
he and going through different portions
I hope in the actual movie that is one
long take because that was very that
would be one how let me go jump through
those bubble things he was jumping
through yeah that about I did a video on
this I'll mention again it's not a lot
of people saw this video that's the X
entertainment invited my best friend
John and I to go watch the trailer at a
theater where they saw who's based on
would do a Q&A oh cool and we went to
the theater to watch it was a 3d trailer
for the second one and the 3d is
phenomenal yeah got to tell you guys I
don't like 3d 95% of the time I avoid it
at all cost actually but watching the
trailer that they showed and with the 3d
it's like when you go to a theme park
and you watch a 3d thing
this is very impressive that's how it
felt it felt like I was it felt
immersive in the 3d yeah this one is one
of the few films where I'm like I'm
going on 3d for sure purrs yeah and on
top of that too wasn't a Q&A actually
there's a Stella bar right across the
street that a few of us went to it's
like only there's only a handful of us a
bunch of this thing and they let us have
like one-on-one conversations with like
Luke based on and Cara Delevingne
what yeah okay we couldn't record any of
it but we got to talk to them oh my god
is he so cool he's really cool he's
really cool he's really you know he has
the attitude like I don't give a [ __ ]
about this press stuff on what director
really does but he was really nice he
answered questions though any question I
asked him I couldn't listen because I
was so caught up into the fact that Luke
based on is looking at me and talking to
me yeah but I would like to Snyder has a
month but I have no idea what he told me
I could have brought this a single I
can't even repeat to you what he said I
could review one thing there's one thing
I can repeat cuz I was like it hit me
Cara Delevingne there was a few of us at
the table of time like it's a small
table we were talking so I was like
alright I want to ask a question because
no one's really asking questions to cut
the Cara Delevingne so I want to ask a
question that encompasses the Bolton I
said you tend to cast strong female
characters what was it about Cara that
you saw that she would do really well
yeah bottom line I remember most so what
he said was doing that thing which is
not in my head but he was saying that
she has an authenticity about her
there's a genuine there's a call about
it's very genuine sincere she doesn't
fake strength you can feel strength when
meeting her like when he met her he felt
that yeah why he cast her and then she
started to get like a little misty on
him so he like had to turn away from
everyone
it was interesting I mean I have to
question that mater Torah dad so sweet
and cool an extra point for you is the
best time yeah a Karns beautiful you so
hot oh my god happening there with those
eyes I don't know how did they come out
that way I think so how do they know now
like how does that happen that you're
just like that beautiful worth like
anyone looks to you and they're just
like it's just she's really stunning in
real life yeah she had like a dress on
that was like up to her you know like
yeah it's oh man she's a sexy woman that
one yeah
totally diggin on me Tara really digging
on you totally diggin oh wow
good job I like to play hard-to-get
I mean it sounds like he didn't laugh
because she's not here now she hasn't
even contacted me but I know she is
waning I know she's just playing a game
I don't think it's called a game she's
like the number one subscriber the real
rejects she probably has like an alter
ego and like at the time that you guys
were dating she was like I'll go and
like it for my extra you know
subscription so that he can feel
validated while we go on her two dates
but that way now she gets into vacations
and she's like I've been done with that
for a while he made me tear up so I
subscribed but now it's like you know
she's done she's over it I mean I'll
tell you guys right now I mean I haven't
seen her since so there's that Tara if
you want to ask me out but just ask me
out don't be like Cara and play harder
to get all right maybe Cara had the
right idea all along which was I don't
respond to burns well Tara god I was
doing so well with the burden listen you
I know Hugh also Gahan Don you think
you're cute are you kidding let's make
out
I am cute like a thing going on it's a
thing because initially I would not be
like oh yeah Han but when that one word
so sweaty and his hair is down I'm like
cool let's let's see where where it
could go he tends to play creepy and he
plays creepy well and he might be is
also a dial tone who knows I really hope
this movie I really hope this movie they
hit it looked like it yeah I hope it is
my concern is is that it's not based on
a graphic novel that is he was like 19
graphic now I know we want it to be huge
like spider-man or our life yeah I put
the work entire dream looks just as good
as any of those other things like I just
think more people need to know about it
yeah yeah right and Clive Owens in it to
Rihanna's in it yeah right that sounds
awesome Clara is great and I think one
thing too that's going to make this
different from films that we're
comparing it to I think this film
because I know Luke based on style one
thing he was saying one of the few
things I actually paid attention to what
he wanted to make sure this film was
just really fun and entertaining he
didn't want to go all out with like
trying to take himself too seriously or
take this project so serious to the
point where it's kind of dull he his
main goal is to make this a very
entertaining film I think it's why the
shredders are so excited and this is one
of the more it's not a serious trailer
but it's more of the serious I would
epic operatic music yeah the intensity
of it all I feel like the overall tone
of this film is probably going to be a
lot more fun enough beat than like
serious space opera well I'm still there
I could see it falling more and with a
guardian of the galaxy than an avenue
yeah but a French fun never heard it
right I never heard anyone
Lauren knows she liked that French fun
with DEET on Dane DeHaan throwing a
third D in there you know what I'm
talking about oh boy
and I like to have fun with Cara
Delevingne yep with his be non-existent
d but on my era a eunuch baby
some women are into that for those one
we're not lazy how are those leaves that
there are to come by
today anyway so you can you take the
Game of Thrones trailer is kind of job
you're gonna go film it into well
subscribe you the real rejects make sure
to check this movie out July 21st 2017
Ryan Fonz our STX entertainment thank
you for hooking up that special event
when Luke bits on and Cardella that
editor hey man thanks for not inviting
me ahead interesting needed to de Honda
Honda hi there go subscribe to my
channel see right there Ericsson I got
our video on their hashtag this idiot go
check it out
we'll have some fun